okay okay chad was live on youtube
hello
[Music]
good morning everybody welcome to the
plans committee of the 2nd of september
welcome to anybody who's tuned in to
watch on our tourist district youtube
site
writing on the agenda this morning
well before i go to that
i'll ask the committee to introduce
themselves
i'll start with myself i'm councillor
chris leather and i
chair the committee and i'm representing
[Music]
good morning i'm councilman and i
represent two rivers and three balls
that's what people watching brody
and i represent benefit east
richard wiseman i represent the cheviot
langtry ward
we know i'll ask the officers present to
introduce himself starting with uh
paul thank you chairman my name is shaun
harrington and i'm the planning manager
of tourist council
good morning my name is damian hunter
and i'm the legal services manager
good morning i'm laura davis principal
planning officer
with listed on the electronics there if
anything goes wrong
our usual
technology which kids on holiday
so um
we've got is it
from democratic services
and then with sandra takes the minutes
over there as well
that's everybody
[Music]
please
that's everybody about from two is that
too abstention yes
too upstaged yes
thank you
item three is
declarations of interest members with
interest to declare
should refer to the agenda item and
describe the nature of their interests
when the item is being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils
who've considered a planned application
by virtue of their membership
of that council
called the personal interest and are
deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the express views of that council do
not by the members concerned
who consider the application afresh
item four is
agreements of the agenda between
parts one and two where we have no part
two
item five is
urgent matters uh i've never have that
was shown again
no urgent message thank you
item six is public participation
we've got
we've got one two three four five
six members of the public
to speak this morning to the to two
applications
cornbread and then four to speak on that
century drive application
and the order of speed this is response
to the
benefit of those reaction on youtube i
think everybody else
knows it the planning officer will give
their presentation
of the application
and then anytime a parish council
counselor would wish to speak for
against the application
they have three minutes
then the two members of the public can
speak
against an application they have three
minutes
and then up to two members of the public
who want to speak in
support of an
they have three minutes and finally
award members can speak
on the application
but there's no limit for the negative
time that they can speak but we
encourage them to be as brief as
possible
i was just being asked earlier by
councilman goff whether we should
declare an interest in relation to one
of the objectives
because she's somebody who dealt with
the campaign at county council and i've
just been looking into it and my view is
that because she's not a close
association or a friend with him that he
doesn't need to declare an interest so i
just wanted us to make that clear as
well to the committee that i've been
speaking tonight okay okay thank you
thank you for that
right we'll move on then item seven on
the agenda is the planning application
the information
recommendations and advice contained in
the reports
are correct as of the date of
preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates
to the reports will be provided in
writing
or orally at the committee meeting
and we'll move on first of all to our
first application 7a
which is an application that
laura who's already sat there waiting
laurie davis will take this application
wayne horn's application performer
thanks laura thank you chair
um this application is sorry can you put
the microphone on copy him
see this is just fully closer to you
laura
i don't think it's all right
i think it's on
any better no yeah yeah
i should turn it around so much fence in
there
oh you're better now grace as well
[Music]
right
[Music]
this application seeks amendments to
previously approved development for 145
dwellings and associated landscaping and
infrastructure on the site so the
description that you have in front of
you is quite lengthy but it effectively
is amending a previously approved
reserve matters application and the
amendment they're seeking to make is in
terms of the layout of the development
the planning history of the site is set
out at the beginning of the officers
committee report and
on pages 10 and 11 of your
officers report
but briefly outline planning commission
was granted in 2017
and for the 145 dwellings we then had a
deed of variation application which was
submitted amending the proportions of
affordable housing and that was approved
in 2018
and then last year we had a reserve
matters application for the details so
for the landscaping the appearance the
layout and scale of the development and
that was approved last year in 2020
so the current application seeks the
amendments of the previously approved
reserve matters
so we're amending the layout of the
development as well as the precise floor
plans
of each of the housing types have been
tweaked
and same with some elevational details
and in addition we're amending
making further amendment in terms of
removing a small number of trees at the
north of the site but we'll run through
the plans
so we've got the application site there
outlined in red we've got cornrow road
across the north of the page
top page and the deer parks developments
which has recently completed is to the
uh right-hand side
next slide please
this is an aerial photograph and the
application site's outlined in red
but just for the members
sort of context if you like the outlined
areas in yellow
are the rest of the allocation in the
local plan under norway 2. so this does
form part of the noro2 allocation
we can go to the next slide please
so i've tried to provide a comparison
for you throughout these slides um of
what was previously approved each time
being on the left
and what's proposed on the right now i
appreciate these quite small plans
effectively the the issue that arose
from the developers point of view is
that there is a rising main running
through
from you can just about see some half a
round about on the right hand side of
the page there in the deer parks
development
um there's a rising mate that then runs
along the axis that comes comes down
thank you very much
and runs into the application site the
angle of that wasn't properly surveyed
previously so they now need to amend the
um
layout to allow an easement either side
effectively the rising main needs to
remain below the access road
um
so that will shows an overview we're
retaining the same number of dwellings
we're retaining the same mix of dwelling
sizes
that's the same number of one two three
four bedroom properties we're retaining
the same number of affordable dwellings
on the sites
we're retaining the
public open space and the leap play
space up in the north
western corner of the site uh we're
retaining attenuation pond in the
south
eastern corner and we're retaining the
the same sort of hedgerows within the
site as previous
uh the applicant has divided the site
instead of four parcels so the next
slides will run through in more detail
the different parts of the site
so this is the northern part so you can
see uh cobra road on the top of the page
there
so you can see the differences in the
layouts and plans
uh but you will see that there are a
number of trees outlined in red next to
the open space those are the ones that
are to now be removed
uh development has
the developers now so ascertain that
those trees can't be retained because of
the gradient and the formation of the
access rate so they're proposing some
replacement planting
for those within the public open space
you can get the next slide please
so this shows next to the parcel of the
site going south
and
shows the link through to the deer parks
development
which is on the right hand side of each
of those plans
so you can see the different angle as to
where the road now needs to run
next slide please
and then moving to the southwestern
corner of the site showing the
differences in the plan layout
and next slide please over to the south
eastern corner
again showing the differences in what's
being being altered
we'll go to the next slide please
um
this shows some of the building
materials now there is a materials
condition that is yet to be discharged
as part of the outline planning
permission but this gives you an idea in
terms of design
um
so the
brownie red kind of color indicates
mainly brick elevations
the dark black or black color indicates
mainly stone elevations
and the lighter colors indicate the ones
that we're going to be predominantly
render so it's a similar mix of
materials across the site we've
maintained
um sort of
feature buildings at certain junctions
and turning points
and in terms of the street layout as we
have before
the next slide please
showing a number of cross-sections for
you um
this is the one of cornwall road so it
shows the relationship to the
neighboring property
which is number 19 shown on the left
hand side there
um
there have been a slight reduction in
the gap between the two properties but
the finished floor levels of the
proposed dwelling nearest plot one
will remain the same and the garage will
be retained in between the two
properties
and then i've just given a number of
cross-sections through the site for you
just to show that they're retaining the
sloping gradient across the site which
is there as existing
[Music]
and just sort of the tweaks to the
design
and to the house types as you go through
the development next slide please
just again going through the main spine
road you can see heading south through
the site shown on on the
right hand side on the little map there
indicated in red
where the cross section is taken
so slight elevational changes
slight changes to the layout of the
development
next slide please
and this is through the main spine road
through the middle of the site which is
where the main alterations are taking
place
so this is looking back north along the
spine road
and the difference is in
the way the houses will be laid out
and next slide please
this shows the
same spot but looking south
across the development
next slide please
so we've got the main planning
considerations set over your report and
as i said before the principle of the
development
to provide the 145 dwellings has
previously been established and there is
an extent of consent for that
and the application site obviously forms
part of the norway ii allocation within
our local plan
in terms of housing mix
the the mix in terms of the size of
dwellings and affordable housing remains
unaltered from the previous scheme
uh the landscape character
and the proposed amendments wouldn't
alter the quantum of development and
would retain the existing hedge banks
and trees to the same parts of the site
as we've previously approved with the
exception of the small group of trees to
the north
next to the public open space
and when considered in context of the
surrounding landscape and the proposed
replacement planting which will be
secured by other conditions and it's not
considered that the amended plans would
result in an adverse impact on the
surrounding landscape
in terms of heritage assets
the application site isn't located
within or adjacent to a conservation
area or any list of buildings and so the
amendments are not considered to result
in a harmful impact
in terms of design the amendments
include minor alterations to the house
types which were previously proposed and
a traditional design to the development
would be retained the proposed mixing
materials is considered to provide a
mixed and varied street scene
the proposed boundary treatments would
be unaltered
and the design approach is considered to
be similar to the previously approved
scheme and in keeping with policy dmo4
in terms of residential amenities as i
say the gap between plot one and the
neighbouring property on cornwall road
is the closest relationship to
an existing dwelling and it'd be reduced
by approximately 0.6 of a meter
we would be retaining the detached
garage
and substantial distance between the two
properties
um an appropriate amenity space is
considered to have been retained for all
of the proposed dwellings
um and we've included condition two
within the recommendation in front of
you this morning which seeks to ensure
that obscure glazing is included for
side-facing windows
and which neighbor another property
which also has cyphers and windows
on that basis it's not considered the
development would be out of keeping with
policy dm1
in terms of highways and access and the
highway access arrangements would be
unaltered
in terms of the access from cornball
road
obviously the diamond sort of the angle
of the road leading from the deer parks
development would be altered
and the proposed parking provision for
each unit would be
unaltered as well
so we're still having two parking spaces
for every dwelling one for each of the
flats
um
in terms of drainage no alterations have
been included to the surface water
drainage or power drainage
amendments um so southwest water have
commented on the development and they've
raised no objection to the
uh development but they have ex
explained the fact that the rising money
needs to be retained within either a new
road or a public open space which is how
it's now shown within the access road
um
number nine the trees um as previously
noted we'll be losing a small group of
trees to the north of the site but the
proposed replacement planting is
indicated within the public open space
and there's no objections to this in
terms of its landscape impact
in terms of ecology
the principle of the development has
previously been established and the
alterations are not considered to result
in the loss of any additional hedge
banks
and the majority are sought to be
retained
we've got conditions included on
previous consents
and to ensure that development is
undertaken in accordance with the
recommendations of the ecology report
and that's also included within this
recommendation in front of this morning
so that's condition four
and number eleven public open space and
play space
and main area public open space um
within the site as well as the leap
would be retained
the replanned layout within the
amendment
would result in a similar if not a
slight increase in the open space areas
across the site
um but the precise amount of open space
needed wasn't fixed as part of the
outline as it predated the current local
plan
in terms of other matters and just to
note to members that there are a number
of additional plans that would need to
be added to the list you've got in your
report and we've also had to update the
drainage plans and landscaping plans
that were approved as part of the
previous reserve matters and so they
will be added on and to any decision
notice that we sent out this
application the recommendation is for
approval thank you
thank you laura thank you for that
presentation
we've got
one speaker to speak in support of this
application
and also a statement a brief step to be
read out from councillor
uh nick laws
one of the westwood hall councils who
called this amended amendment
application
so um first of all
we've done the hygiene
[Music]
jamie grant will speak in support of the
application
thank you chair
um good morning um as the applicants um
i am here speaking in support
of this application which seats um what
provides layout ultimately really
um i've been involved in this particular
project for about
two years now i suppose um wayne holmes
um started looking at it um following
approval received by the promoter
um at that point we obviously then took
on board on the information submitted
and um were transferred or documents
submitted to kind of inform that
original outline application
um so i suppose i i'm the planning
manager so i've had um involvement with
detailed design from that point onwards
really um we had numerous meetings with
torridge um
application advice
um which informed
our detailed design really now we
ensured that the
the original submission um conformed
with the grant is established within the
outline consent
and also the feedback received through
those on meetings with torridge
um so that application was submitted on
may 2020 um those minor tweaks as you'd
expect throughout that process it was
approved almost a year ago
um
since then probably about two
two months afterwards um we had ground
workers on site um that then
they did a technique called slip
trenching
so based on the previous surveys um
carried out
um they dug in locations nearby the pipe
and they couldn't find anything um which
obviously um raised numerous alarm
valves
uh we then located the exact um
location of that um that southwest water
pipe and um i have to kind of decide
what what we did from then on um we had
numerous meetings with south southwest
water
um it was agreed the best way to deal
with it was to re-plan perception of the
site now obviously it's not as simple as
re-planning a small section because you
design a um at this stage you design a
site to know the factors that go into
that you have to be considered such as
levels and the knock-on effect of
retaining structures so it wasn't a case
of simply realigning the road and
planning around that it obviously has a
knock-on effect
so that's when we started looking at it
in a bit more detail um
i think our my main consideration was
ensuring that what we put forward to um
torridge um kept within the realms of
the of the previous permission and the
outline consents
um so taking that on board we submitted
a revised plan that has the same housing
mix same material palette
same ecological mitigation slight
increase in pos and certainly more um
usable
space anyway
the
this is a scheme that we put forward is
very much just trying to counteract the
impact of that um that pipe um
so i think what from my point of view
what i'm asking for you is to look at
this for what it is we're in no way
trying to um pull the wool over your
eyes or gain anything really we're um
we're trying to resolve a problem that
was very much outside of our control due
to
inaccurate survey information that was
handed to us over two years ago
so we're in an unfortunate situation we
hope it's never been again
and going forward because we've put
processes in place that doesn't happen
again and i think we're trying to learn
from our lesson really
um so i just i just hope that you um
apply consideration of the officer's
report on your supporter thank you
thank you
[Music]
and then
[Music]
manager has got a short statement from
councillor nick laws
one of the westwood hall district
councillors
thank you chairman
can members hear me okay
so this is a statement from councillor
laws
if you could give my apologies to the
committee for my unavoidable
non-attendance and have my statement
relevantly for every time i would
appreciate it
this application falls over my ward and
i'm sorry to say it contains none of the
feel the wonderful countryside it sits
within
i have studied the plans and when i
imagine myself walking through this
estate there are no hidden corner
touches of countryside consideration of
the wildlife no village shop no cafe
just houses
where will the residents meet
i appreciate none of these within the
power of the planning committee
i served on plans and targeted the 90s
i feel for the planning committee you
have to consider this application in
isolation
i'm sure it fulfills all the necessary
criteria and policy needs i however have
the luxury of looking at all the
development of upper westwood home as a
whole from davenhill going west there
will be no nearly a thousand houses with
no real infrastructure
i would ask the committee today to look
at the identity of the housing on the
site compared with its neighbor as it
appears to be greater i would request
the committee to ask the planning
officer if this is the case and if so
what is the maximum density per acre
allowed and whether the committee can
take into consideration the
infrastructure needs of a thousand
houses and not just look at this
application for 145 houses in isolations
in isolation regards council nick laws
are you sure
[Music]
right that's the uh
the end of the speeches
so i'll throw it over
to cancel a lot
of things that with regards to capital
laws it's calling uh reasons are they
particularly relevant to this
application or do they in fact
we made to get my application it's
already been granted because it's
talking about density and that's not
actually changing i just wonder if they
are relevant to this application
[Music]
and
i'm aware of counselor laws and comments
and
obviously the application has previously
been approved with the same number of
dwellings on exactly the same
application site so
you know it's not really for me to
comment necessarily on it but all i
would say is the fact that these are
things that were considered as part of
the previous permission
um and so we are where we are if you
like and we have already got an extent
consent which can be built out on the
site
thank you councillor christie
yeah thank you um
well it was a shame we reduced the
number of affordable houses last time
but there we are
um can i just ask that often page 10
a high wage contribution
340 000 of which 200 000 is towards
improvement of the
the roundabout basically um
the bottomless pit as this money seems
to go to but i do notice it says that um
the remainder towards one of the
following highway schemes
can i ask as a committee can we specify
which one we want now because i will
press very strongly for number four
um this has been support this is the
cambridge valley cycle group this has
been supported by both biddeford town
council and northern town council
uh
at the moment it doesn't have any
funding this would be really useful if
we could earmark it for that because
then we could start doing the actual
real work on it can we actually specify
that at this committee
obviously the section 106 was agreed as
part of the outline planning commission
and this is a variation of a reserve
matters so i think the remit's fairly
limited it might be a question that goes
directly to the county council highways
officers in terms of actually how
they're intending to spend the money
now the development has commenced i'm
sorry
sure
if i can just add to the office's
comments
the section 106 has been ingredient has
been signed as central members
appreciate um that element in session
106 was requested by devon county
council
so it would be for denver county council
to make that decision although i'm sure
that um we can discuss the county
council and i'll be doing kind of
council with the members preferred
options there but ultimately it would be
democratic accounts for making that
decision
thank you for that can i ask our county
councillor over there
i hope he lobbies for this because
otherwise this money just goes into this
central pot
and we never know where it goes and
i've no idea how much money they've
already got stacked up for the
roundabout because it keeps
every scheme we get oh we'll take two
hundred thousand we must have the money
by now
can i ask our counselor could you look
at this because well councillor um goff
will be aware that pittsford town
council has supported this and northern
downtown as well and i'd like it to be
here mark if possible thank you
thank you councillor christie i think
members realized that
this site's already got had a reserved
matters application approved and what
surprised me that
none of the district westwood district
council has called the original
one in once the outline had been
approved and then the reserve matters
came in that was the time really to have
called pulled it into the committee but
this is really
an amendment
um
[Music]
which normally would have just been
discussed with the planning officer and
the ward members these amendments but
they are council
yeah i mean the number of hours is
remaining the same and 25 percent the
forward are remaining the same
um
and the prime officer actually
welcomes the revised layout
so isaac knows robert and i would
recommend approval
thank you
thank you councillors and council watson
you're setting in the recommendation of
approval i will agree with the
councillor christian the spend of
which would be 140 000 plus
200 000 to the roundabout scheme that
seems to be swallowing a huge amount
of 106 money and then that means 140 000
well at least i would expect a good
chunk of that to be an earmarked for
this site the chemist valley cycle route
from midfield through northern to
westfield
but it's been moved for approval by
council a lot
seconded by councillor watson
and all those in favor of it please sure
thank you
we are still recording the vote
somewhere thank you for that
thank you take the vote please
[Music]
thank you
i perhaps should have been introduced to
the committee and officers sorry we've
got northern town councils karen clark
in our wrestle
back there is taking notes and
she's doing some research because she's
doing a degree
course and
this is a specific piece of research
i invited this morning
[Music]
um
foreign
uh
[Music]
right our next planning application is
application on the agenda 7b
which is century drive northern
sir boyle is the planning officer and
we'll give this
presentation and there are
two speakers members of the public to
speak against the application
and two
and
two speakers to speaking support to the
application
just before we carry on
you're in the room yet so for us sorry
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'll start again because members of the
public are being asked to wait outside
downstairs until we
uh reach the application that they've
written to to speak to so i'll start
again we've got four speakers
um to speak
to this application as jane whittaker is
speaking against matthew
speaking against if i pronounce that
certain card
mr roberts speaking in support and mrs
roberts speaking in support
and sarah sarah
boyle is our planning officer who will
present it sandwich there thank
you so the application is
10697 of 2021 and it's full application
and it's for the alterations and raising
throughput to create additional
accommodation at 29th century drive
so the application has been called in by
councillor leather um and it was subject
to a virtual site meeting last week
so just to give a verbal update um there
was amended plans um for the application
that were submitted um and we went out
to reconsultation because there was
objection comments that reconsultation
ended on the 24th of august so obviously
after the committee report was was
written
um so we had um one update from the
parish which um put that they would just
agree to note the application so they
put no further comments forward from
their original comments
we had one new objection comment um
which
the concerns and issues raised are all
ones that have been raised by other
neighbours so we we have already kind of
considered them in the report and then
we had two updated comments um from
objectors that had previously submitted
um who both summarized that the changes
still didn't address their concerns so
so there's no new kind of concerns that
have been brought forward um they were
just updated comments but they have all
been received um and i checked today and
there was no further comments from from
today
next slide please
so just to show you the site so this is
the location plan so the host dwelling
is 29th century drive to the east is 27
and to the west is 31. so it's a
residential estate and these dwellings
are towards the western edge of it um
and they are accessed through kind of
their own own drive not off the main um
estate road so this is in northern which
is a main center designated in the north
devon and torridge local plan
next
so this is just showing you the the
existing site plan at the moment
and so you can see to the to the east
and the west the dwellings um of 27 and
31
next side please
and then this is the proposed site plan
showing the the dormer window on the
north elevation um and you can see the
roof changes to the to the south and the
west
next slide please
so these are just some of the photos
um so this is the the north elevation of
the dwelling at the moment
and as you can see
on the the right hand side of of the
screen that is 31 century drive
next slide
so this is just taking kind of a step
back at the kind of the bottom of the
drive which leads up to 29 and 31 so you
can see the relationship there so you've
got 27
on the left hand side then 29th century
drive and then 31 on the right hand side
of your screen
and this is just showing the difference
um between 29 itself and 27 so you've
got the boundary treatment of the fence
there and then you've got a gap before
you get to 27
and to show you the height difference
that in the bridge height of the roof at
the moment
so this is looking at at 31 century
drive um so you can see at the moment
that is that ridge height is already
higher than 29th century drive
so this is looking to the to the south
of the dwelling
and so on the western
side they're simplifying the
um the the roof and then obviously they
are going up by 1.1 meters
this is just to show a better angle so
this is 31 century drive
and the relationship to 29th century
drive at the moment
and then this is looking in the other
direction so you've got 27 cents drive
with with the ridge height so 29 already
sits slightly higher
in terms of roof height due to the
topography of the land
so this is looking from the existing
balcony that's already um at 29th
century dry so this is looking towards
27
and then the next few photos are just
kind of a pam round of of what they
already see from this balcony um this
balcony will remain but it's just going
to be counter levered
um instead so
if we go to the next slide
so this is the view looking kind of to
the north east
it shows kind of the bottom of the
driveway up to the two properties
and then the next light
shows you to the north
and then the next slide
shows you kind of to the north west so
that is the the driveway of 31.
and then if we go to the next slide
this is kind of on the western side of
the balcony that's already existing
looking at 31 century drive
next slide
so um within my site visit i did go into
31 century drive to take um photos from
from their perspective so that we
addressed all concerns and issues so
this is um one of the photos from a
landing window in 31 then if we go to
the next slide
this is looking from the the kind of
inside the door of the balcony that
that's at 31 already looking across to
um
29th century drive so you can see the
the relationship that's there already
if we go to the next one
so this is just taking a step kind of
further forward to show you that the
views that they they can get already
from from 31
next slide
so this is going further up into
obviously the the dwelling of 31 that
you can already see from the window the
roof um
the original application had that
western gable end higher and they have
now reduced that so and they'll point
that out in in the proposed drawings so
this is the existing ridge height
so this is from um one of the the top
rooms on the top floor
um of 31 century drive looking
um obviously at the ridge and obviously
looking towards the north east there
next slide
and that's just showing another angle
from the window of what what 31 already
see from from their dwelling
this is just one for for any councils
that haven't um seen it is this is a
dwelling that has been amended further
down the road and as i say in my report
quite a lot of the bungalows now have
been amended through extensions um
different materials and alterations
and this one actually was allowed on
appeal a few years ago
so these are the existing plans so this
is the existing north and east elevation
and then next like that is the existing
south and west elevation
so these are the proposals that have now
been put forward like i said these are
amended plans the balcony um on the the
top floor originally spanned the whole
width of the dwelling they have reduced
that now um so they've brought it
further in um to try and overcome the
concerns with with 31 century drive
as you can see the bottom balcony is
still staying and that has been um
counter levered the ridge height is
going up by 1.1 meters so about 3.6 feet
next slide
so this is to show it from the south and
the west so as you can see the the
western gable end now is
um the same height as as what the
original um dwelling wasn't and that's
just been simplified and then you've got
1.1 meters the cheek of the doormat has
been extended to obviously
act as a privacy screen and kind of
enclose the balcony on that side so that
they
kind of limit the views that they've got
to the to the western side
so these are just the existing floor
plans um to show it goes in at kind of a
garage and office level and then goes up
to the to the main area
and then these are the so this is the
proposed ground and first floor
um so rooms are changing but but not
greatly altering from what's already
there and then the next slide shows the
second floor which will be um
incorporated with with the ridge height
next slide
so the material planning considerations
in this case which have all been outlaid
in the outlined in the report is
principle of development
the impact on character and appearance
the impact on immunity
access parking and highway safety and
ecology
thank you
so yeah the recommendation is to grant
this application
thank you
sarah thank you for that
right our first speaker
speaking against it
this application is jay whitaker if
you would like to come up to the
microphone
please and when you settled if you would
uh
like to speak right into the microphone
thank you you'd have you've three
minutes to address the committee thank
you
right thank you chairman can you all
hear me yeah i appreciate the
opportunity to speak against this
application but would really rather not
be doing so as we've always had a decent
relationship with our new neighbours
because of the footprints of the two
houses as they are they were looking in
respect to this application has become a
huge concern for us
before jeff sold the bungalow it
originally had a balcony that ran the
whole length of its front but in order
not to cause any concern in respect to
privacy for either house he reduced it
to its existing length
so we don't overlook our neighbors and
they really cannot overlook us in any
discernible way
the existing balcony is now a good
distance from our house
this application of granted will change
all of this
especially as it will be a floor higher
and will project out from where the
current guttering is by almost five foot
so it will impact considerably on the
privacy of our main living area
screening its end closest to us will
help in respect of the privacy from my
bedroom window but not from anywhere
else
approval will mean quite simply that our
privacy and our immunity space will be
hugely compromised and this should not
be happening in terms of policy alone
the house down the road number 23 was
refused and granted at appeal and i know
that this concerned the case officer
when she visited us
but although in terms of height and mass
it is different than the two surrounding
houses there are no overlooking aspects
to
either of its neighbors which is maybe
why the inspector decided to grant it
however from 29's perspective
perspective overlooking is very much an
issue which can be seen from the inside
of our home which when can be seen from
our inside of our home is easily
understood
i would hate to think that number 29's
recommendation of approval is only as a
consequence of the success of number
23's approval at appeal
there are no real similarities to
justify that decision while there are
valid reasons to refuse it
primarily protecting our privacy and
immunity space alone
is of great seriousness to us
thank you
thank you
now our next public contribution is from
matthew phillies
who's speaking against the application
and again once you've set we've got
three minutes to address the committee
thank you
good morning
certainly the alterations for 29th
century drive rule for the occupiers
fantastic accommodation
with a double height on lounge ceiling
i'm not dissimilar to this room here
actually when i look at it with the
highest points
and this is going to be achieved by
raising the rich of the existing pitch
group by 1.1 metres
better accommodation could be achieved
by not doing this by um in my proposed
uh letter of proposal um the door
the door could actually be taken from
the front of the property to the bank
without actually raising this rich
height and that would have significant
improvement in terms of the visual
aspect of its property
and the
surrounding areas
the proposals as they stand i feel are
going to be overbearing
they certainly will um dwarf the
property to the east i think it's
another 27 century drive um by nearly uh
three and a half meters as the person's
shown
i'm also concerned as jane is with the
privacy on her property and on the
balcony uh even in its amended form uh
overlooking her property
i i think also with the um property
becoming a three-story building
you've got uh you're opening the
floodgates for century drive to change
significantly with similar properties
which is normally um bungalows
single-story bumpers also becoming
three-star properties and this is going
to lead to increased parking on the road
which is quite narrow as a turning head
at the end of the of the road
and that will cause future significant
problems
the visual impacts from
northern boroughs also be made worse
because there's a separate player
application to remove 15 signal trees in
front of the property i think this
should be taken into consideration that
this is it's no longer going to follow
the natural topography of the ground
it's going to be significantly higher
and be seen from
all over westwood and northern
so
i think having 30 years of construction
experience as a charge of civil
engineering i've seen the impact of some
fantastic decisions made in planning and
the life lasting life long lasting
emergency of poor decisions i think
there could be an improvement with this
application with some compromise
thank you
thank you
thank you and our next speaker now is in
support of it is mr roberts
and once you've settled
you you have three minutes thank you to
address the committee
good morning
my family and i really love our home we
want to make it our home forever the
amendments
we want to make people allow us to enjoy
visits from friends and family providing
more dining space and one additional
bedroom we're not doing this to sell the
property we'll move on but to maximise
the stunning views and give a 1970s
house a new lease of life
my wife and i work from homes we spend a
lot of time here with our wife with our
daughter eight years old who attends a
local primary school in many after
school clubs and we really enjoy the
beach live so this home was perfect for
us
i believe we've now addressed councillor
leather's concerns
raised by number 31 century drive we did
this without hesitation as we do not
want to damage the good relationship
with our neighbours
we have the full support of the torridge
case offer who has quite clearly stated
she recommends approval for this
development in line with policy we have
addressed the concerns with the revised
design
i do not believe the proposed bias the
balcony causes any issues with intrusive
overlooking or loss of light to our
neighbours the balcony faces to the
north maximizing the view over the
northern boroughs
and not directly at our neighbours
the property of 31 century drivers to
the west
with only their driveway in front of our
balcony as you can see from the
photographs this area is already clearly
visible from our current balcony in
livingroom the new balcony will have
little effect or privacy or overlooking
because no living areas will be affected
the current owners of 20 31 century
drivers used to own our home and they
built their property in our garden
around 2007-2008
as you can see from the photographs
their kitchen and balcony extends out to
the north away from the street line so
it looks east towards our home
please note the plans were also
submitted by the owners of 31 century
tribes include a loft conversion and
dormer windows installed in our home at
that moment in time
as you can see from the latest plans
we've reduced the balcony substantially
from the west and have incorporated
additional privacy to the side of the
dormer to prevent any perceived
overlooking from the additional floor
our planned development will have no
negative impact on the streets
of century drive due to the property
being set back at private drive as you
can see
and you have to make a concerted effort
to view it combined with the
contemporary design language used by
several recent developments in the
northern area namely the visitor center
and the cafe and new dwellings of durham
lane i believe it's hard to argue
against our design our development will
have no impact on traffic or parking
currently the driveway can support
parking for four cars plus the garage
while building is underway we'll be
moving out to the property freeing up
parking for contractors
other objections that come from houses
behind stem stem from a perceived loss
of view unfortunately no one is entitled
to a view and i feel a small rise of 1.1
metres would have a little effect on
their properties with them being
significantly higher at the slope plus a
long distance away with two gardens
between us
thank you for your time
thank you mr robert
[Music]
and our second speaker in support of the
application is mrs roberts
[Music]
when you settle you you two have three
minutes
to address the committee thank you
thank you hello we moved into our home
in 2016 we knew immediately we wanted to
raise our young family here living here
for five years we've seen how the space
works for us and how it could be
improved we're planning to convert our
home from a three bed to a four bed the
office we have downstairs is used daily
by my husband and i where we run our
business from and is separate from the
rest of our home
it also has a low ceiling and concrete
block walls
and is not practical to be used as a
bedroom or living space
as for the design we have opted for a
modern and contemporary design as we
want to move with the times rather than
replicate the original 70s look or go
for a dated design
we are asking to the raise the reef just
over a metre
to give us enough headroom for the loft
conversion which then puts the roof
height halfway between the properties on
either side this is not dominating and
the precedence has already been set by
31 century drive which substantially
overshadows us and 23 century drive who
turned their bungalow into a house we
feel a 1.1 meter extension is a modest
and fair request
we have had extensive discussions with
the case officer and our neighbors at 31
and as a result we have reduced a new
balcony in terms of its length and depth
we had a good relationship with them
since moving in and we were hoping that
the relationship would continue and
therefore we were willing to compromise
we've also reduced the height of the
roof adjacent to number 31 as it sits on
the boundary and the revised design is
actually lower than the current
arrangement
as part of the discussions we've also
provided additional screening to the end
of the balcony to eliminate any
perceived overlooking when we are on our
existing balcony we look out to sea not
directly onto our neighbor's property so
we were surprised at the objection with
regard to privacy
number 31 rotates 90 degrees at the end
with a balcony which looks directly onto
our driveway and home at the front it
seems unfair that they can have a
balcony to look directly at us but they
object to us having a balcony looking
out to sea
number 31 is a large property on a small
plot built too close to our home that's
the words of number 31 not ours
it seems we are having to compromise
greatly on our design because of the
mistakes they made when building their
property
our case was called to committee
specifically because of the balcony we
immediately made substantial amendments
to this feature the case officer is now
happy with the design and is
recommending approval
as it is in line with policy and
protects everyone's privacy yet we are
still here for you to make the decision
i'm not sure why we were taking up your
time today with this application and i
really hope that it can be resolved
today thank you
thank you mr roberts
that's the last
the last thing that i'll just give a
minute so that um
[Music]
sarah can come back to answer any
questions
i will just say that
when i originally i called in the
original application
and as i've just been said because of
the balcony stretching the full length
and
it might be there was an issue
of serious overlooking of 31.
i've got 30 in the golden rates 30 more
actually
um
i use the prerogative that plans
committee members have of calling it in
taking the black box which doesn't
indicate either way whether you're in
support
or opposing an application
and since
the amendments the amended plans came in
i've still left the call in there
because i thought
i waited to see what uh comments came in
to the amending plans
um i noticed the town council haven't
altered or i did anything to what they
said originally so that was the reason i
called it and and the reason i didn't
withdraw my calling was because i
thought
i didn't want to
[Music]
tip my hand over there with us
but i do accept that the alterations
have been made
to that bill balcony by reducing it
three meters
i don't know who would like to start
the discussion on this
or
i'll continue
[Music]
i mean
i'm happy to recommend the approval of
the application because i do think
that the alterations the amendment plans
have addressed the primary concern that
i have i did put in potentially have a
significant
impact on the street scene but
that was potentially and i don't think
there isn't a significant impact from it
on the street scene and also the raising
of the ridge 1.1 meters in old mummy and
i like to deal in old money still about
three foot seven inches
is
is not the eight feet that i read
somewhere on the objectives of which
and also the balcony has been reduced in
width not just in length but it's been
reduced down now to 1.3 meters again
four feet three inches wide
so
and and then that screening at the side
so i'm happy to move a recommendation to
approve this
[Music]
i mean a lot of the reasons not hatching
material banning considerations i mean
much was made in the
[Music]
holidays but i mean we've just got to
concentrate on what is in front of us we
can't speculate what's what is going to
be used for whether they're going to
change the office into the fifth bedroom
or anything like that
um
i was rather perplexed at northern town
council's response on the 27th of august
when it just said agreed to note this
application they didn't say whether they
you know supported the amendments or not
so i was rather puzzled at that and then
if if you read gw architects
letter
um i think they made rather a gross
error because in that letter they say
hopefully the street drawing
demonstrates there will be an issue with
privacy and overlooking
i think they should be exactly the
opposite of that otherwise they weren't
actually their clients best interests
um if the application is approved
on page 34
[Music]
that is something that could we could
add as a condition if if that would be
saturated we would just say there wasn't
a formal kind of um
ecologist report but we could put that
either as an informative or if you would
like it as a condition it could be put
as a condition
yeah
[Music]
uh
yes i think um it'd be reasonable for
condition to be added that works are
carried out in accordance with the
submitted ecological
impact assessment um which some short
case officer will confirm
um did have that line about in the
unlikely event of that is discovered or
what in the city should be should cease
and the license plate ecologists
consulted so if we were to condition
that should take place um in accordance
with that assessment i think that'd be
reasonable
[Music]
yeah there's been no evidence of any
backs in that
we'll have that but
a conditioning council watson
just have a look at the the
situation with the balcony
yeah uh and i think we said something
about this it's been screened
yeah so if we go to
the next slide
yeah so if you see on the west elevation
there what they've
done is widened the dormer cheek
so that it prevents it rather than just
kind of putting an obvious kind of 1.8
meter screen up which would draw more
attention to it they've tried to
incorporate it in the design of it um so
it got put forward that they would
enlarge kind of the dormer cheek of it
to act as a as a protection screen but
obviously the balcony has been reduced
by three meters and as councillor
leather said it has been reduced in
width as well back down to 1.3 meters
[Music]
drive has different heights and scales
of buildings
all the way through
and i do feel that the applicants have
done everything they can really to
mitigate any problems
so i've got no problems
well i
move the recommendation to approve
nobody step did it yet
that's something counselor chris is
setting you
so if nobody else wants to make any
comment
sandra would you take the vote please
yes chad thank you cancel about them
councilman
[Music]
[Music]
during the comments so i said that they
shouldn't be involved involved in they
have to go to the toilet so i said
full comments from all the members
yeah
sorry
but we're
[Music]
personal reasons health reasons
unfortunately suffering from a prostate
moment but are you up to date
i'm going to say anything sir just carry
on
i'm not saying that they just just crack
on it
carry on
council watson
yes
hence the wise men or
that's eight four
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you
i understood damien he said
there's no
to the toilet and that's just one of
those things
this week is
processed by the speakers usually
we would stop them in january
[Music]
somebody needs to go to the toilet and
usually stop and have a comfortable well
i didn't know anybody wanted you well we
he just had to leave so you don't really
get much of a choice
it's all right it's just that i just
wanted to confirm that you had the
opportunity to speak to that application
if you wanted i think that's not what he
was speaking i just said
speak to him
okay
[Music]
yeah
um
[Music]
right okay
this is agenda item 7c
and debbie
this thanksgiving
morning councillors and members of the
government
uh okay so uh this application is before
committee because uh
so
yeah next slide please
so the application is for the erection
of
agricultural livestock building
the floor space is about
450 square meters
um
in the report it's 12 meters by 36
meters and five meters in overall height
so
this is the location plan it's near
bradwell
west of bradworthy
countryside
it's located
in the farmyard itself with other
agricultural buildings around it
next slide please
elevation so
agricultural building yorkshire boring
it's for housing
calves which i saw when i was on site
next slide please
so that's looking back at the site
uh where the actual
location for the building and that's
looking away from the site to the east
so the nearest residential property
which is about 100 meters away
um environmental protection were
consulted and have no objections
with that distance
obviously
livestock buildings
have uh residential immunity issues so
they were consulted on that natural
england also consulted and have no
objections
so as you know we've got an spd
for um
agricultural emissions uh this
building is of a scale which is less
than the threshold for that
um so they have no objections to the
application next slide please
um this is actually
street view but um you can see that the
impact form
it's going to look very similar to the
other buildings so from the street
which you see as another agricultural
building
and the hedge partially screens it and
the landscape is relatively flat there
and it's not a designated landscape area
so
um in terms of that
that's
acceptable next time please
so material planning considering
considerations are
principal obviously agricultural
development in rural areas is acceptable
character and appearance at the same
relatively flat
not a designated
area about studying natural beauty
will look the same as the other
buildings
uh west central community
100 meters from the nearest residential
property
[Music]
got no objections from the environmental
protection
access is the same
there's
not considered to be considerable
additional traffic created
flooding and drainage
uh is using the existing
system
it's outside of flood zones to approve
from the environment agency and
the applicant has demonstrated how the
surface water will be managed with the
existing system
and in terms of ecology it's not the
application is not
large enough to trigger
an ecology or report
and
there's no requirement in this instance
for ecological enhancements so um in
terms of
the application is pretty
straightforward it's being called in
sorry hasn't been called in it's come to
committee
because of the council of autumn um
because it's his application so
um
i recommend him
parenting application thank you
thank you debbie
yes thank you chad
i don't see anything wrong with this
application at all and i know debbie is
um
very good with planning applications of
the new agriculture and i
propose that we've run
thank it council watson thank you
councillor brown brown deceptive
anybody else want to make comment
that is in my view straightforward
agricultural application so it's been
proposed by councillor watson sent me by
councillor brown
to grant this application
thank you chad
that's about him
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
sorry richard
[Music]
[Music]
is
an application of broadband and uh peter
stapler the planning officer will take
this
presentation thank you speaker thank you
chad um good morning members and members
of the public my name is
officer
council and
i'm the case officer for this
application for the site and direction
of the timber um summer house in the
garden
the property known as newlands
next slide please
so the applications come to committee
today because the um applicant is a a
family member
officer
council
and here we have the location plan
of the application site and you can see
the dwelling known as newlands there and
assessment
you can see the red application site
at the south east of the original
dwelling
next slide please
and again to the blue outline and it
shows the ownership of the land and the
weather outline shows the application
site and again
in relation to the original dwelling
house there and the garden area the
south
[Music]
this is from the highway access and
looking north west um
you can see
with the church there and also normally
access for the original dwelling house
next slide please
and here we have highway access looking
southeast
country lane
so this is the
access um this isn't in the red outline
but it's within the blue outline um
in the aerial images it's the original
house and with the access um
[Music]
so just a bit of context the application
site so on the right you can see the
original dwelling house and the red
arrow
to the left there you can see behind the
bush and north beach hedge is the
application site and where the location
of the summer house is going
so this is the current um application
site uh just garden area and used in
connection with the original dwelling
house previously
and again you can see that it's just
right there kind of just in the context
and the church behind
and the original dwelling house on the
left there just see the top of it
again this is view of the
application site
come south there is a an agricultural
field um
and again looking west there's a number
of trees and edges which screen
[Music]
this is a view from the public highway
so
um i'm still on the public highway here
and
and the application site is behind the
hedges and you can see everybody there
so we'll be visible from that public
highway
the next slide is
those elevations and floor plans and the
summer house
[Music]
material considerations in the terminal
of this case for the principle
development impact on character
appearance
impact on immunity
access park and highway safety and
ecology
and i hope you all have my report
as to why i'm recommending an approval
of the application
lovely thank you
oh
so i recommend that the application is
approved thank you
thank you
[Music]
all right um so
yeah
i'll i'll take a bit thanks again to the
watson yeah i did wonder myself yeah
right yeah all right it's been unless
anybody else wants to make comment
it's been recommended to grant this one
council lock recommending council watson
certainly that can you take the vote
thank you chad
thank you
for
chancellor brown
that's the christie oh that's
[Music]
agenda is a field
decision summary at pages 51-54
you see the
the one on bayview road that is refused
under
officer recommendation has been
[Music]
reasons are in there
item nine on the agenda these
costs will appear no costs
item 10 on page 55
of the other delegated
about the agm beast chef
paige 54.
i missed that
yeah pete yeah thanks cancer watson
yes
delegated decisions air gmb
on page 54 not 55.
you see before they're permitted
then we'll move on to planning decisions
on pages 55
to 64.
these are
applications
the decisions made between
the 23rd of july 2021 and the 19th
of august
page 55
age 56
page 57
h58
h59
a60
361
[Music]
page 62
and
base 63 with the not permitted
development to the bottom there
that's requested i missed it but on base
60.
[Music]
richard should know that yeah
yeah
what did they do then just go from that
just
it's nice to learn at least one new
thing you know what a long-term area
so
thank you everybody thank you to those
that have watched this on youtube
for their attendance thank you to all
the public speakers they've left thanks
to the officers in fact all the
committee members